let us pray
Oh God may the words of my mouth and the
meditations of all of our hearts be
acceptable in your sight for you are our
rock and our Redeemer amen good morning
it's so good to be here with you this
morning and I especially thank our
pastor Ian for this kind invitation and
our chaplain Sharon for her leadership
and religious life in this fine
University it is such a privilege to
have the opportunity to share some
thoughts on Scripture and on the Trinity
and on réunion a Sunday here as I travel
with my family my daughter JJ and my
husband Dan for my 20th reunion hey gene
hey Erica great to see everybody here
feels like 20 years ago all over again
I'm having flashbacks it's not always
good but it's mostly and I take as my
text this morning the twelfth verse of
the sixteenth chapter of the Gospel
according to John I take as my text this
verse I still have many things to say to
you but you cannot bear them now Jesus
says to his disciples I have many things
to say to you but you cannot bear them
now in the portion of the passage that
follows this verse jesus foreshadows
that the Holy Spirit will come and will
shape and prepare the disciples to
continue in their ministries of loving
teaching and healing to anyone the
concept of the holy spirit the third
person of the Trinity who acts as a
metaphysical helper to Jesus's followers
is pretty abstract even worse Jesus is
foreshadowing this abstract concept to
the disciples before they
only know that Jesus is not going to be
with them for much longer they don't
know yet that Jesus will be arrested
while they fear for their own safety and
that after the devastating loss of
Jesus's crucifixion he will be raised
from the dead and will ascend into
heaven in other words Jesus is
foreshadowing an abstract metaphysical
concept to a group of people that hasn't
been through what it would need to have
gone through in order to have the
vaguest notion of what he was talking
about no simple task knowing that the
disciple disciples have no frame of
reference for what Jesus is hinting at
Jesus speaks obliquely and vaguely and
tells them that he's limiting his words
based on their lack of readiness he says
I still have many things to say to you
but you cannot bear them now maybe Jesus
would like very much to talk with his
friends about what's going to happen and
maybe they would very much like to know
when Jesus tells them that they aren't
ready I'm sure he's right but i can't
imagine his disciples agreeing with him
i don't know what your experience has
been in the past when it comes to
telling people they're not ready for
something in my experience those
conversations haven't gone particularly
well ever told a young adult that you
don't think he's ready to get married
right after he's come to you with
excitement and joy ever told an employee
that you don't think she's ready for the
promotion for which she's been striving
ever told anybody that you don't think
they're ready to hear something that
they think they want to know
conversations like these are hard on
everyone they're hard on the one doing
the saying and that the hearer doesn't
know what he or she doesn't know and the
Sayer can't really explain that those
conversations are hard on the hearer in
that the one who hears might actually
feel quite ready to hear and believe
simply that he's not being understood
even worse the one hearing she isn't
ready might on some deep level actually
know that the one who's saying so is
right and that hurts even more I had an
experience just a couple of days ago
where somebody told me I was not ready
for something me I was not ready for
something really seriously yeah Sarah
you're not ready you're not ready do I
sound bitter
do I sound the little little consumed
now not not no Viet not in the least not
unless there's no big deal there's no
big deal at all well I wanted to work on
a particular writing project related to
my research and it's kind of a long
story but the upshot was this I was
given the feedback that my research idea
didn't seem ready for prime time I
needed a lot more work than I thought it
did and would have to be delayed until
both I and my idea were more ready again
this was no big deal really I didn't
want to have a productive summer anyway
with this recent exchange I had a chance
to ride the wave of what it feels like
to be told I'm not ready for something I
felt myself relating to the disciples in
our passage today imagining what it
would have been like to hear Jesus say
that they no matter how much they loved
him and cherished him and strove to
follow him they weren't ready to hear
his words the feelings that came over me
were confusion hurt rejection hearing we
aren't ready doesn't feel very good it
doesn't feel very good at all father
Michael Himes is a Jesuit theologian at
Boston College who created a video
resource a few years ago for college
students on discerning vocation or
figuring out their sense of calling in
this resource father Himes names what he
calls three key questions and he says
that we must ask ourselves the questions
in order to know where God is leading us
in our lives the questions are first
what gives me joy
second what am I good at and third does
anybody need me to do it father Himes
takes great pains with the second of
those three key questions what am I good
at he makes clear that people can figure
out on their own what gives them joy and
they can figure out on their own where
opportunities to serve might exist but
to figure out what we're good at
actually requires other people other
people actually have to tell us whether
we are good singers or joke tellers or
biochemists or ministers in the same way
we often have to rely on other people to
tell us whether or not we are ready for
something we kind of always think we are
but even when I consider younger
versions of myself I know that this is
simply not true there were lots of
things that younger versions of Sarah
thought she was ready for and lots of
cases where a younger Sarah was wrong I
needed others to help me see that in my
post Yale days I got really interested
in adult learning theory among the five
or six widely agreed upon nearly
universally accepted principles of adult
learning is the concept that adults
can't learn something they're not ready
to learn readiness is one of the
required precursors of adult education
the logical question for adult learners
is therefore what does it take
to become ready to learn adult learning
theorists most notably Malcolm Knowles
argue that adults learn what they need
to learn in order to adjust to life
situations in other words we become
ready to learn because we have to an
adult who loves somebody with a
disability can quickly become an expert
in treating or living with that
disability Kate Rhea and Morgan O'Neill
who survived the tornado in munson
Massachusetts last May created resources
on community organizing around disasters
that volunteers in Moore Oklahoma are
using right now they learned what they
knew about disaster relief through an
experience for which they did not ask
necessity breeds readiness we can see
echoes of this form of readiness the
readiness bread of necessity and so many
other parts of life I teach ministry
students about faith development in my
classes at Andover Newton theological
school one thing we know about faith
development is that our face evolved as
we are ready for them to evolve but they
become ready to evolve when they have to
consider this example a young man
immature in his face feels threatened by
the beliefs of another he worries that
the other person's beliefs will infect
him with doubt he encounters someone of
another faith through a life situation
he can't control when he is assigned a
roommate raised in another religious
tradition suddenly there's no more room
for him to avoid the other person's
beliefs quite literally
no room so his faith has to evolve so he
doesn't feel threatened all the time so
he becomes more mature in his beliefs in
order to flourish in a new life
circumstance similarly anyone who's
worked with the addicted knows that an
addict can only find help in treatment
when she's ready that readiness often
shows up in an addicted person who's
fallen in love or had a child because
the addict needs to find healing in
order to hold on to something more
important suddenly she's ready to learn
what recovery would take I'm here
celebrating my 20th college reunion as I
make my way through my visit this
weekend I am painfully aware of how much
I didn't learn here because I wasn't
ready to learn it the years I spent at
Yale were among the four happiest of my
life and there's no institution in my
personal history about which I have fond
or feelings than Yale but I could have
been here a hundred years and still felt
like I missed a lot of learning
opportunities and a lot of other things
too yet when I consider that which I did
learn I can see in retrospect I learned
what I had to I learned within an hour
of living on Elm how to cross an urban
street with the light I learned how to
live away from my parents to make
conversation with a nun housed neighbor
and identify my own passions when faced
with an overwhelming array of options
jesus knew the disciples weren't ready
to understand the concept of the Holy
Spirit at the moment he was trying to
tell
them about it they had to go through
hell to get to a point where they could
possibly grasp the notion of a good
metaphysical friend that would be God's
presence among them during what would
become Jesus's very long absence in a
way this might have been a blissfully
ignorant moment for the disciples we
have to remember unreadiness isn't all
bad necessity breeds readiness but
necessity isn't always very much fun it
can kind of stink sometimes necessity
the 90s metal band poison might sing
sometimes I wish I didn't know now the
things I didn't know then the disciples
weren't ready to understand the idea of
the Holy Spirit because Jesus was still
with them they hadn't yet experienced
the horror of his humiliating death nor
had they witnessed the glory of his
triumphant resurrection but in their
unreadiness and this is the important
part they didn't do anything wrong
they're only human just like us this is
the good news there's nothing wrong with
not being ready for something there was
nothing wrong with my Yale self who
didn't know she should have tried crew
she should have taken a course with
Peter salle ave I mean seriously how did
I not take a course with Peter Salome
should have spent even more time with my
friends although I did spend a lot
should have fed even more time with my
friends when they lived no more than a
city block away
many people advised me to do all of
those things when I was a student here
but I wasn't ready to hear them oh well
what are you going to do the feeling we
have of sadness or in competence when
we're told that we aren't ready is the
voice of shame and the voice of regret
in us it is not the voice of reason it
is not the voice of kindness and it is
definitely not the voice of God God at
work in us helps us to say through the
Holy Spirit you know what maybe I'm not
ready God isn't finished with me yet as
a Christian I believe that we know now
only in part and only God knows fully I
believe that Jesus was God made
incarnate on the earth and we see in
Jesus glimmers of what God is and what
God knows about us we strive over the
course of a whole lifetime to follow
Jesus and to be more like him and as we
do that we become more and more ready to
learn who God is and what God is calling
us to become in our passage today we see
that jesus knew his disciples he knew
what they were and weren't ready for in
the same way God knows us and reveals
God's plan for us on God's time not our
time as we try to place our trust in God
we face moments when we're told we
aren't ready and we face them with
humility and we face them with hope
we welcome the life experiences that
will help us to be ready to learn and we
trust that they'll bring us closer to
the God who knows us who knows
everything and is our ultimate
destination thanks be to God amen